[Music]
cold today my talks about it's called
serious gaming it's kind of about
building educational games and
JavaScript has anybody here ever built a
game in JavaScript even just for fun
cool there was like 10 people in the
audience that had done it it's fun
there's there's one guy going crazy so
it's good he sounds like he had some fun
with it yeah so kind of the main things
that I want to talk to you today is
about it's kind of a journey how over a
weekend I became a game developer and
how you guys too can become game
developers and make games for learning I
think I think there's not enough games
for actually learning stuff so about two
years ago I moved to Thailand and I
never spoke Thai I didn't know how to
read or write Thai I don't know anybody
here know how to read Thai there's like
two three okay there's a couple people
cool so I came and I come to this new
country and I'm like okay I'm gonna make
some friends and I want to start talking
to people and nowadays nobody calls each
other right we don't talk on the phone
we're always on like whatsapp or line or
Kakao chat or whatever and what I found
was I I wanted to talk to people and my
conversations always ended up like this
where you have these here - yeah where
all we do is we just send stickers to
each other like okay this is great like
okay I'm hungry I'm sad you know and you
can kind of get some of the way with
stickers but I really wanted to like
learn how to write and like how to type
so what ended up happening was I just
like you know what I'm a programmer why
don't I just make a game to make myself
be able to learn Thai so I actually
built a Thai typing game well I first
went on the internet and there's been
like two typing games made in the last
ten years and they're both awful and I
was like I just can't be
hard oh why do i why don't I try this
out if you guys have ever seen well this
is actually a picture of the game so
this is a copy of the game on iOS it's a
pretty simple game but it's it's kind of
a lot of fun and just a really quick way
to like incrementally grow tie and and
learn a keyboard and you may be asking
yourself why why is it difficult why why
would you go through all this trouble of
building your own app to like learn how
to write Thai well this is the Thai
alphabet and that's not two copies of
the same keyboard it's two keyboards so
like you literally have to hit the meta
key to get some of the characters right
so like when I started typing I wasn't
hunting and pecking I was like sitting
there for like five minutes like every
key press would be like I don't know
where go guy is so I was like oh man
this this has to be better it has to be
better it has to be a better way to do
this and that's kind of what started my
journey building this game so just
really quick a little bit background
about me I'm a server-side developer I
mostly write go and you might be asking
yourself why is a go developer here
talking about JavaScript
I love JavaScript and my main my main
day job is writing server-side code so
like it's a nice like weekend thing to
write JavaScript particularly front-end
stuff you know just kind of totally
different element I have a book coming
out later this year called micro
services and go you should check it out
and yeah and I live in Bangkok cool how
many people here are gamers yeah cool we
have a I figured there would be a lot of
people in the audience that are big
gamers and you know I mean there's a lot
of types of games right there's games
like World of Warcraft where you know
you're just you know you're grinding
you're doing things and people play
World of Warcraft because it's fun it's
social they get into it and like they
play with their friends but there's like
this huge spectrum of kinds of games so
I
I don't know if this game was really big
in Singapore but it's the number one
game in Thailand and it's it's a
Japanese cat game it's called neko
atsume and all you do is you put stuff
around and you collect cats and people
spend hours playing this game and what's
crazy is there's no time it's only in
Japanese
there's no English subtitles or anything
but people have learned how to play this
game just because they think that it's
really fun and you'll see people on the
subway in Thailand almost spend like 30
minutes just playing this game and it
blows my mind and this game the only
thing I can think of it's just for time
wasting but I want to talk about it
something that I really what I'm really
passionate about which is serious gaming
and serious gaming is is building
educational games for learning whereas
like when we when you know when we're
taught math as a kid you know like we do
our math facts and like we have to like
do the questions and the answers and
we're like why can't we make this fun
instead of just giving somebody a gold
sticker like why can't we actually make
an interactive game that like helps
people like learn how to do math or how
to read or do these kinds of things
right and so when I was growing up we
had we had like Atari two's which I mean
Apple two's excuse me and we had lots of
really fun educational games and I don't
know what's happened because I feel like
they've kind of gone away and in a sense
so like when I was growing up I don't
know it has anybody played any of these
games by the way yeah okay people
there's some older people here in the
audience these these are really old
though there's like Oregon Trail and
Carmen Sandiego and math blasters and
the best one my favorite one was always
number munchers and it was just a game
that taught you multiplication in
addition but you didn't think it was a
game you just played it because it was
fun and then all of a sudden you knew
all your multiplication tables it was
really kind of a crazy idea and but
there was like tons of these games and
they were really easy like these ran on
like one megahertz computer
it's like why can't we on the web now
remit games like this for kids like why
can't we make it fun for kids and people
to learn things and there's this kind of
other area of gaming is gamification I
know a lot of people probably build
business apps does anybody here use
gamification like in their apps at all
not many actually just three or four
people okay so Gama fication is kind of
like this thing that's come out over the
last years and I don't think is as
effective at education but basically
Gama fication is we want to give rewards
we want to give points we want to like
you check in you become a mayor like we
have an app in America called Foursquare
where you check in and you become a
mayor of a building and it's all around
points and games and I feel like it's
fun but at a certain point if your bank
website gives you points for like
checking your checking account at a
certain point you're just going to get
really bored with getting points on
every single thing that you do and it's
really cool so I mean we do some of
these kinds of things like you know you
still want to have like level ups and
points and being able to show share to
your friends but I really think the
future of educational gaming is about
making the games fun how do we make a
world of warcraft that that teaches you
how to do geography or something like
this like that that's what I really
would like to see and and and the whole
reason and obviously this is java
circumference so yes I am gonna get to
actual JavaScript programming so why
JavaScript has has everybody read this
book by the way javascript the good
parts come on there should be more
people in the audience this is
absolutely the most important book
you'll ever read on Java scale of
analysis which guy and I look this is
like one book that I love but why did I
pick JavaScript like you know like I've
done C++ a ton C sharp I've done all the
stuff I could write a native app and I
and I thought about it and I was like
well I wanted to build this in a weekend
I wanted to just do this without any
trouble and just
wanted to do it fast and I was like this
is really the reason I did in JavaScript
is because every time I make a change in
my code that the app just reloads itself
it's like interactive programming it's
kind of like what they've always talked
about and having a good IDE is like um
as I'm changing the code I like I have a
bigger monitor at home so I literally
just keep the app on one side and I keep
the JavaScript on the other and every
time my editor saves I actually use this
thing called I use this thing called
browser sync I don't know is anybody
here use browser sync or something
similar
that's okay so this table over here is
like they raise their hand for
everything so they're probably very
advanced or they like raising their
hands yeah so browser sync in gulp you
should really check it out because
basically for like 10 lines of code you
can point it at your your asset folders
and I even do like asset compilation
even if you're doing CoffeeScript or
whatever it will automatically just
reload the browser and what's cool is
that it actually inserts JavaScript into
your HTML page and that javascript has
like notifications so like if something
changes on the file system it actually
pings the code in the browser and
reloads the browser so like if you're
building a game what I do is I just like
disable all the menus and all this stuff
and I always just have the game levels
pop up so like as you're coding you're
like oh no that the the character he's
like 10 pixels too high well let me
change the 10 pixels and literally like
in a second you'll see that the 10
pixels come down you know it's not like
if you guys have built like a game in
like C++ you're like okay well now I'm
gonna like recompile the whole thing and
I'm gonna wait five minutes and oh no I
didn't get it it wasn't 10 pixels it was
actually 12 pixels off stuff like this
so I think that was one of the biggest
things that like JavaScript there's no
way I could have built this game in like
three days the first version was
literally three days like so so this has
kind of always been my sticking point
about JavaScript I don't know does
anybody hear fine like JavaScript
projects get pretty messy
if they get really large like it just
kind of comes like this big bald mod of
chaos a lot of times and like all of a
sudden you're in like this class and
it's actually attaching something to the
window that's used in like six classes
away and nobody knows because it was
written five years ago and like and this
has always been like my pain whenever
I've come into a lot of JavaScript
projects and I'm sure a lot of people
here are using it but I use this tool
called requirejs and requirejs lets you
do is like you make sure that each class
is kind of very separate and you kind of
you can you can kind of separate your
different parts of the code very cleanly
so for a game games come out pretty
cleanly so like you know the hero is a
distinct class you know each monster is
a distinct class you know each kind of
level is a class even things like the
kinds of labels that we have like we
have special like scoring labels and
stuff like this and it really kind of
gave you a really nice way of
structuring the whole program so it felt
a little bit more like being a
structured language like C++ or I'd you
go and and but still got to a lot of the
speed and development of JavaScript so I
don't know if anybody's here if you've
looked at JavaScript game development
libraries when it when it came into this
project I was like all right there has
to be nice game development library in
JavaScript so of course I go on Google
and I look and there's only 300 so this
should be easy to pick from so I think I
got by by about the third one I was just
like all right I think it's just faster
just to pick it and start programming so
I don't have like a huge extensive
knowledge of all of them I tried a
couple like impact GS but it ended up
with this one called create GS and
what's kind of cool is it's written by
some guys that used to do flash this guy
game G Skinner and since he was a flash
developer he kind of had all the ideas
about what are the core elements of like
building interactive applications you
know like you know like how do I make
things anime
how do I have like transitions how do I
have tweens and and just really just
very small core building blocks it
doesn't try to be like I don't know if
you've seen other game libraries where
they're like you know you end up just
making JSON files to control levels or
if you use like unity maybe you like try
to like use some GUI app like it's it's
just like the bear kind of fundamentals
that you would need and since not a lot
of people have actually built games here
I'm gonna kind of talk about really the
small fundamentals of building a game
just a 2-d game you know this is like
all Mario area stuff so like it's not
advanced and it's really easy and it's
kind of fun so kind of the one of the
the main building blocks of a game is
you have that animations right so we
have you know we have monsters in the
game and we have the characters and
basically what boils down is you have
these things and they're called sprite
sheets you know they can be cells or
whatever but basically what happens is
you have like a giant horizontal image
so like each one of these five things
here is one image and basically you
break down the frames of the image into
like separate blocks so if it's by 40 by
40 you're lining it up and you say like
40 and then at 80 pixels there's the
second pixel picture and at 120 pixels
there's a third picture right so as you
do these but what's also cool is you
might have multiple different animations
in one file so like if we look at the
monster there we have we have two we
have two animations we have one where
he's like chomping and then we have one
where he's dying and and we look at the
each of them we have like but sometimes
we might so not whereas like on the
third one down we just have one long
really really long animation so we can
kind of mix these up how we want and
what's kind of cool is the code is
really easy for this so like we're
looking at the monster we're actually
looking at one of the monkeys and in the
framework all you're doing is you're
defining which frames go
each animation so you say like frames 0
1 2 3 4 5 go to the run and you can even
reuse them so sometimes maybe the jump
share some of the run animations and
then you can just and you just set up
names and then we just create a hero
with the sprite sheet and you place them
on the screen and that's as simple as
creating animations and when you want to
play it so like let's say that we're
playing through the game and we kill the
monster right to actually just kill the
monster to run the animation you run one
line of code and it's just it's called
go to and stop so it runs the animation
and us to the end of the animation and
it's that simple like it's 15 lines of
code to set up an animation and to place
it on the screen and then one line of
code every time you want to play it so
it's it's about as simple as it can get
and and that's kind of one of the things
that I want to kind of convey through
this whole thing is basically it's
pretty easy like it seems daunting like
you see games and like you don't have to
make like 3d unreal game like there's a
lot of fun two teams it's like the cat
game we showed earlier it isn't it
there's no like advanced technology that
could have been made on a Super Nintendo
you know so kind of the next building
block that we have in kind of 2d and 2d
game programming it's called the
parallax scrolling and this is kind of
like if you ever played Super Mario
Brothers I don't know is how many people
I don't know if that's too old in this
audience okay okay cool
actually half more than half the
audiences play this good so basically
the whole idea of Super Mario is Mario
doesn't really move that much it's
really the background of the screen that
moves so I just want to really quickly
show so like this is actually the game
right so like this is this is actually
all those elements put together inside
of one of the levels in the game but if
we break it down into pieces it's really
four different graphics that are really
wide and kind of the idea with a
parallax is that you have different
parts of the screen and they move at
different speeds so the clouds might be
moving really slow
the city scene might be moving very
quickly and then the middle city scene
might be moving just a little bit slower
and then the ground just barely moves
right and it creates this effect as
though you're walking through the screen
but all you're doing is you're just kind
of you're just shifting different
elements and what's kind of cool is that
it ends up being like a circle so like
the clouds we don't have infinite number
of clouds right we're just basically
circling around a circle so we like are
just showing a portion of the clouds at
any pour it's important the time so
maybe like on this screen here we might
be showing maybe a quarter of those
clouds especially on iOS where you're
not gonna you don't have that much
resolution so you as you can see we're
only seeing like a very very very small
fraction of each piece but it kind of
moves around and it kind of gives the
impression is that that you're really
kind of moving through this city soon so
let's let's talk about the code and once
again this is really easy so basically
for parallax you basically are just for
each one you give it a name you give it
the dimensions and you give it the speed
the rate that it's going to be moving so
some are going to be moving at you know
point so many milliseconds and each one
will be moving at different milliseconds
and then the actual implementation of
parallax itself is only ten lines of
code in JavaScript you're basically just
taking the velocity and you're basically
just moving it around the x-axis at the
velocity that it needs to go so like and
if it loops around we just start over
from the beginning so it's it's it's
really really easy it didn't even have a
parallax implementation I just got this
off the internet I was like ten lines of
code it was it it's it's really fun
though so now we have kind of the main
building blocks of like a 2d game like
we can we have the characters we can
make big characters animate and move and
we can move the background as though
we're walking through the screen now how
does the main game loop work in a game
so kind of games are kind of built
around state machines
so basically what happens is every time
there's a clock tick so usually you'll
divide a game into like 60 frames a
second or 30 frames a second and you'll
have an event which is your clock tick
in create yes they called the update
function and once every so like if we
have 60 frames a second so once a what
once every one 60th of a second will get
an event and basically what we'll do is
we'll decide at that point in time if we
need to do an animation or maybe we need
to scroll the screen some and and
basically we're just doing it a
fractions fractions in fractions of a
second and the main game loop as you can
see here you can maybe I can't see the
code gray but it's only maybe about 50
lines of code and we'll just kind of
talk through just kind of the main
elements of how how a game loop actually
works so like as I said it's a state
machine so like for example if somebody
hit the pause button the function
shouldn't do anything right so it starts
there and then if if we're in the middle
of a monster dying so like an event so
like a monster dies well that's not
instantaneous right because it may take
a second it may take a half a second for
the animation to play through so you
have to keep you have to maintain these
states and you have to see if we're if
we're done yet with each of these kinds
of states and then for each kind of
thing on the screen now it's granted
like this is a pretty simple game so
like I explicitly mention each monster
and each hero like if you're building a
bigger game you would have like a linked
list or a map of like all of the all the
objects that you would have on the
screen and you would iterate over them
but basically what you're gonna do is
you talk to each object and you tell the
object to render itself and and
basically in in like the hero or in the
monster they know about time so the hero
he's running so like every so often
he'll be changing frames of his run or
if it's the monster he'll have to be
checking to see if the hero intersects
with with the box so like if the monster
and the hero touchy
the hero dies shame these kinds of
things so each of these classes is like
responsible for its own for its own
functionality and it kind of breaks in
like that so then yeah so so and then
yes then there's the collided so we
might do things we play an audio we
might lower the health and for our game
since we're building something that
actually is tracking words per minute
we're gonna start calculating the words
per minute and update any labels so like
we have labels on the screen if I come
back here we have that's yeah we have
labels on the screen like the time the
words per minute how many points we have
and we have to kind of keep track of
those and like every time we do an
update and then the very last thing is
we iterate over all the parallax layers
that we talked about earlier and we we
make sure that they get updated so like
we just talked to the parallax which we
talked about here and the parallax knows
how to render itself what's kind of cool
is like the main game loop just kind of
knows about objects and then each object
is kind of responsible for its own
rendering it's kind of very similar to
like when you guys do like angular or
any of these other component frameworks
but now we can do this with like games
and it's it's pretty straightforward if
you've done any kind of other game
development so that's kind of the main
glue that's that's basically all the
main things you need to like break down
a game and we've talked about maybe 150
lines of code for the core of a 2-d game
that's that's pretty reasonable for
anybody starting out to just like flip
through right so cool so I'm going to
talk about some of the other cool fun
libraries that I found for doing game
development with with this there's
another library called creatine and once
you start to get a more complex game
like so once I started to have multiple
levels and stuff I wanted to be able to
like actually manage the levels in a
sane way and this creatine framework
allows you to do like level management
transitions between levels it can even
do things like did anybody play like the
old Final Fantasies were like you have
like this 2d yeah
plantain yeah I see a couple of people
smiling so like the old Final Fantasy
games were all they call it I so more
Trek Norfolk where you're looking at a
you're looking at an overworld and you
move through this overworld and it has
kind of cool things for that so if you
guys are like if anybody's thinking
about like building like a 3d like not
3d but like a like an old-style RPG like
there's classes where like you just spin
up and you just give it some graphics
and all of a sudden you have like an
old-style
RPG like right out of the box so I'll
talk about kind of what I ended up using
it for I ended up using it for managing
levels and what's really cool is like
they have this thing called the level
manager in the directory and you
basically you set up all your types of
levels and you can even make things like
the main the main entry screen to the
application and the settings screen are
kind of levels and you can shift between
them so like you can kind of make them
you can almost think of it it's like if
it was like divs of different pages and
you're replacing them it just handles
like transitioning like like say if we
want to transition like ever every after
every level you want to have a level
complete right so you want to transition
into a level complete and then
transition into the next type of level
and is this kind of framework just kind
of gives you a really easy way of
handling that and keeping that and a
nice clean kind of more object-oriented
fashion so there was a whole talk on
this which is great I hope everybody
heard the talk this morning which was
really great how many people are
actually using PhoneGap or cordova for
production stuff that's cool there's
actually quite a bit of people yeah it's
really exciting like if you haven't
checked it out and you might be like
well what why did you build an HTML game
and then why do you need to produce
cordova why don't you just put it on the
web wouldn't that be awesome
so I started off and I was like oh this
is awesome I built it on OSX I built the
whole app in a weekend I was like oh
this is really cool and I don't really
typed I on my OS X I always type on my
phone because I'm always talking with my
friends if I'm talking inside and I was
like ah cool I'm just gonna throw this
on iOS it's gonna be no problem like of
course I throw it on there in like 95
percent of it work
right and it's like this is always the
one thing that always is annoying with
JavaScript there's always like that last
couple percent so there was a couple
issues that when I ran to and I
originally put it on iOS so things like
the native keyboard so one of the things
is a lot of typing games if you look on
the App Store I don't know if anybody's
ever played they make their own fake
keyboards which is really annoying
because I like the iOS keyboard and I
really want to learn how to type on that
I don't want to learn how to type on a
fake keyboard so if you want to actually
control the iOS keyboard for good reason
Safari doesn't let you control how it
pops up and stuff like this so this is
one of the things that you actually have
to go to native code for and and
actually be able to handle the the
popups the other thing was there were
certain times where the whole game would
just pause on iOS in Safari like when
you are playing there's like sometimes
when you're playing sounds or sometimes
when you're using the keyboard like the
game would just like it would just pause
and there was just like nothing you
could do so these were the kinds of
things that like I ended up using
Cordova for and ended up being really
easy I thought it was gonna be hard
because they were like oh you can build
native code and I hadn't hadn't used it
before and I was like I'll cool I've
done objective-c I'm gonna write all
this objective-c and then I go on the
internet and I find that everything that
I ever wanted possibly was already
written in Cordova plugins so so you
don't have to worry about doing
Objective C or Java if you're doing an
Android app so for example I used two
plugins from Cordova one in one of them
is the keyboard plug-in which allows you
to have like manual control of the
keyboard so you can actually like force
the keyboard to pop up and do things the
other really cool thing that they have
in Cordova is background audio so like
the audio actually plays on a background
thread and it doesn't interrupt your
JavaScript so like there's times like
when you're playing like like sound
loops where like Safari was pausing I
was having issues with this and like as
soon as I put it in Cordova and the
really other nice thing about it is it's
runtime in a like you can just check it
at runtime so like if I run this app on
my on my laptop
it doesn't use
Cordova and it just checks and it just
uses the native browser audio function
so it's it's really easy to kind of
integrate it into your apps like just
piecemeal this is fun I saw I just got
this about a week ago I don't know has
anybody got in to play with electron yet
it's quite new it's okay for people good
awesome so electron is kind of like the
new hotness it's kind of like the next
PhoneGap it's by the github guys and
basically it allows you to build native
applications in JavaScript both on OS X
and Windows it's not more it's not for
mobile as much it's more for desktops
but what's kind of cool is that it
packages Chrome with your JavaScript
application so like kind of annoying
because like on iOS you always have to
have Safari and I I personally like
coding in Chrome better than Safari so
like my app always just works better in
chrome so this this is kind of cool and
the other nice thing is if you want to
package it up for the Mac App Store or
the Windows app store you can actually
create a binary to distribute with your
application and I thought oh man this is
gonna be a pain in the neck this is
gonna be like all this hard stuff to set
it up and it I turned out like you write
one javascript file and you write like
40 lines of code in the JavaScript file
and that's it and you're done and
basically all the code is is you're just
defining how large you want the window
to be and like defining if you want it
to be fullscreen or not and it's just
this really really simple stuff and and
in like five minutes you guys can have
like a native OSX app and it looks like
an app and what's cool is you can have
like the nice icons and stuff like that
so it looks like it's like the native
OSX apps in fact I spent more time just
trying to get code signing to work on
OSX which is a real pain like to do that
to get in the Mac App Store like that
was that was a bigger nightmare so I'm
gonna give you a demo of this code but I
just wanted to wrap up and kind of bring
back a couple points I'm I don't use
JavaScript for my day-to-day work but
making a game in JavaScript was really
easy
I think you know I would avoid the
cross-platform tools honestly unless you
really have a need like I had a need to
use him I spent more time futzing with
couldn't with PhoneGap then I would have
liked and its really easy to get going
in a game writing a game in JavaScript
literally over a single weekend you can
put together a game no problem
so I I really encourage it I would love
to see some games for kids
i I I want to make some games around
math like this is kind of what I want to
do this is all open source it's on my
github which I forgot to put a link to
but if you if you hit me up afterwards
also to you and if you want to pack it
if you want to make a Chinese version or
a Korean version I kind of want to do a
Japanese one next because I'm learning
Japanese but I would love to see some
other people hack on it and I'm going to
do a little bit of demo because we have
a few more minutes and then then I'll
open up for questions in a few minutes
so cool it's just nice so basically what
I was talking about at the beginning of
the presentation where I use gulp and
Bowser jams so basically I just run gulp
and it sets up the entire environment
and it runs the app here actually I
don't have a Thai keyboard on this
laptop so I'm gonna actually just change
this to English for now I it's funny
when I was developing the game I didn't
I couldn't type Thai fast enough to
actually develop the game so I had to
put an English mode in cuz because
otherwise I was like I could never get
to the end of the level it was really
bad it's really funny yeah so so what's
kind of cool is I want to just
so what's cool is now since we're in
JavaScript obviously we have our normal
JavaScript console and everything like
this now there are some things missing
right cuz this is just a giant canvas so
we can't like do introspections so like
if we inspect the element really we just
have a giant canvas right we're just cuz
we're just doing 2d bleeding we're not
actually using HTML elements at all of
this I mean it's almost like making a
game on a console and in that kind of
sense but what's cool is like now that
we're in JavaScript we can actually do
things like we can look at we can
inspect elements on the stage and stuff
like this let me go so like for example
if we wanted to change the word in the
middle of the the running we can do nice
things like this so we can actually
check it and and this is I love this
workflow so let me get at it full screen
so yeah so my development workflow is
like this where and if you have two
monitors obviously I found this so much
better because I used to like to hack on
games in C++ when I was much younger and
this was always a nightmare cuz you
would like you would want to tweak
things so like you don't have a GUI
editor right so like if you wanted like
if the monster is like offset by ten
pixels you don't have any way of like
easily doing that you have to change the
code right it's like every time you
wanted to change the code so you know if
I wanted to make the monster like jump
here and we that we could actually just
change it and see if that
it's not good yeah so it just makes it
really easy so this is I really like
this workflow and I'm going to show you
there's only a couple thousand lines of
code in this whole project and it gets
broken out pretty easily so that's
that's pretty much it I'm gonna open it
up for a few questions now yes thanks
Matthew
so any questions for Matthew so what the
artwork for the game oh um I have a
designer friend
yeah that's oh but what's cool is
there's actually a lot of open source
game artwork especially if you're
building 2d games I don't have the links
handy but if you just google to the open
source there's actually a huge
communities because a lot of people like
to remake the old RPGs like the Final
Fantasy type games yeah okay yeah
question is there like a framework
that's react based for game because this
seems like a really good you know demo
or the use case yeah I don't know of one
that react but see the thing is is that
I don't know if you would need to
because a lot of the stuff in like react
or angular are built around HTML
elements and this is like you're
building a canvas like it's it's kind of
like you're just doing 2d bleeding so
like I don't know if it would help you
as much as you would think there's not a
whole lot to it actually solution or you
just write a hole for the text one for
though say that one more time no
collision oh for the localization oh
well
localization happened to be easy because
I live in Thailand so I have lots of
people that speak Thai around me so I
got it for free it was pretty oh if you
want to you want to localize the game
yeah so the way the way you would just
do the localization is pretty easy just
like any other JavaScript app I would
probably just have a map
of strings and the way I've always done
it is just have a map of strings and I
just swap out this strings
nothing fancy or different in a game yes
from the last road sorry the performance
when it was released how was the
performance on the devices Oh
so I mean performance wise like were you
getting 60fps or was it yet so the when
I first wrote it I didn't even try it on
the device and when I first ran in on
device it was 60 frames a second until
it's popped until it was 0 frames a
second but once what happened is I ended
up figuring out there are certain
trigger points in Safari like when you
talk to the keyboard like it would just
pause the whole thread and that was the
main thing was just getting around these
there's a couple bumps where it would
but like on an iPhone either five or six
is the main ones I've tested it's 60
frames a second with almost no tuning so
right so I guess what you men show
before you can use the console like the
JavaScript console or the chrome console
to modify things so in a way it makes
people possible to hack your games is
there a way to yeah okay so the question
is is it's cuz it's a JavaScript can
people hack the game yeah of course but
that's kind of fun I kind of like that's
why I liked how the script is cuz like
if somebody wanted to tweak it like you
know sometimes I was finding something
annoying you could like skip a level in
the game right it's kind of like when
you're a kid and they had like the cheat
codes for the game but in this the cheat
codes are you actually learn something
so I mean I think it would be very
difficult to stop right the only thing
you could really do is try to make it
something on the server side if you had
a server-side game but yeah I don't
think you can stop it completely make
sure that is fun while staying simple
right oh that's that's a great question
how do you make sure that the game is
fun well simple and that's why I think
you got to throw away a lot of
prototypes so when we originally made
this I'd made that we were making this
with a graphic designer friend of mine
and what we did was we ended up taking
like ten different
versions actually I would like to show
we had tender we had ten different like
iterations we did in just like Photoshop
and we just played around we were like
okay would this work would this work and
we didn't even write any code and even
if you don't do Photoshop I would just
do it on paper and like just go through
different concepts because like we came
through I mean this isn't even that
complex of a game but we went through
early ten different ones that just won't
make any sense at all all right Thank
You Matthew
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]